[Music]
[Applause]
barry trammell covers the oklahoma
sooners the great columnist for the
oklahoman and he joins us now if i told
you a week ago lincoln riley was going
to be the usc head coach you would have
said what
i said uh it's possible but
it doesn't seem likely but it's possible
i was pretty sure he wasn't going to lsu
but turns out maybe that was a trojan
horse all that sec you know lsu or
florida or wherever um going to
going to southern cal makes
some sense when you think about it
if a coach doesn't want to jump into the
into the den of vipers that the sec can
be
um if he wants to replicate what he had
at oklahoma usc is a pretty good place
to do it that's a place he should go and
could quickly dominate the conference
yeah i understand that where oklahoma in
the big 12 you're kind of separated and
you go to the pac-12 you have that
opportunity to stay separated you go
into the sec
you know
this ain't the big 12. how much do you
think this is him running to usc or
running away from the sec
i think well i mean i think it's the
same um
if you ask me if oklahoma hadn't joined
the sec or the
intent to go to the sec would lincoln
riley still be the coach i think the
answer is yes
really
yeah i i don't think he wanted to to go
to the sec um i think he'd been
successful there but the success level
would have been different from what
oklahoma is accustomed to dominating the
conference you know they lost bedlam
saturday night that ended six straight
years of winning the big 12. so
um that's that's sort of the standard he
set that's the standard he expects
you're not going to do that in the sec
alabama doesn't win six straight sec
titles and they're alabama so
uh i think he can go to usc you know you
the pac-12 is sort of
open range anybody that's ready to take
over it's it's there for the taking and
somebody like lincoln riley could go to
could go to l.a and do just exactly that
so the wish list at oklahoma starts with
who
well i mean i think uh
oklahoma's sort of a unique place
they've
at one time in their history literally
have they hired a sitting head coach
that was howard schnellenberger in 1995
it was a disaster he lasted one year
they've always hired an up-and-coming
assistant coach they believe in their
program more than personality
barry switzer bob stoops
chuck fairbanks bud wilkinson i mean all
the big names had never been head
coaches before they got to oklahoma so
uh
that's not necessarily what they'll do
now the transfor portal changes
everything
in the past when you change coaches you
had to worry about your future rosters
and recruiting now you got to worry
about your current roster keeping people
together uh you need sort of a steady
hand that could mean uh that could mean
uh an immediate uh
wisdom is needed guys who can keep the
ship going
in terms of names being thrown around
shane beamer at south carolina he was on
lincoln staff until a year ago
he's he's a guy to look for because very
impressive
the beamer family is as classy
and as well respected as any in america
and that's not just frank shane is the
same way oh you loved him if he was
still on lincoln staff i think he'd
already have been named head coach
so he's one to keep an eye on uh the
sooners we'll talk to brent venables
also 13-year assistant of bob for bob
stoops went to clemson 10 years ago and
has helped dabo swinney build an empire
uh he's only 50. been coaching
uh you know 25 years in college football
but he's only 50 years old he will be a
viable candidate and i think ou will
look at some of the some of the hot
coaches the guy i think to keep an eye
on is matt rule
who did wonderful at baylor he's always
wanted to coach in the nfl he's now been
there two years
i don't know if he likes it i know that
if you go to the nfl and don't have a
quarterback
it's not that great of a job so is matt
ruhl ready to come back to college i can
say this
i've been covering college football for
40 years most impressive
person i've come across as a coach slash
personality
in coaching is matt rule so that's who
that's who i would call so those are
some of the names
what about bob stoops
uh bob stoops i don't think wants to get
back in the car okay but what a great
what a what a great resource he is to
step in and be able you know try to try
to keep things steady here for the next
week or month or every how long he needs
to be the interim coach
uh
bob got away because of the stress he
got away because of the demands he got
away because of the social media and the
changing times uh bob stoops not into uh
he's not into tick tock and nil that's
not his deal so
you know that's what you got to be if
you're a head coach these days
uh what would you say to usc fans uh
listening to this in los angeles of what
you're getting with lincoln riley
he had a fantastic coach i mean he's he
does everything in a classy manner now
you know you fans don't like the way he
left or that he left or
whatever but uh he's an he's a great
coach
he's not just an offensive savant he's a
great leader he's a good he's a good
administrator he's he's the sharpest guy
in whatever room he walks into
um
i mean it's a home run hire for usc
there's not any question about that the
only question i would have for usc is
how long can you keep it does lincoln
eventually want to go to the nfl if the
answer is no
you're going to be you're going to have
a good coach for
uh for quite a while and i think i think
you trojans will ascend to the top of
the pac-12 pretty quickly
great to catch up with you as always
barry thank you for your time
you bet thanks that's barry trammell
covers the oklahoma sooners for the
oklahoman